hello and thank you again for joining us
for this NCBI minute today we will
explore the safe search feature which
can provide automatic email updates on a
daily weekly or monthly basis and
conclude with creating a customized name
collection from our search results that
can be made public to share with others
let's get started with saving and
managing a search the easiest way to
begin is at the PubMed homepage located
at w WM AQ V if you're not already
signed into NCBI don't worry you'll be
prompted later for my example I am
automating my PubMed search for at
lesson COPD step one is to enter my
query or search terms if you're
interested in this tutorial on how to
construct a query information will be
provided at the end of this presentation
but in general the pubmed process is
from left to right and dates and ranges
are not recommended for save searches
step 2 click the search button next
create alert which is located beneath
the search bar a pop-up window will
appear again if you are not logged into
your NCBI account you will be prompted
to sign in now it's time to save the
search name the default is the search a
couple of things to remember the save
search name may be up to 100 characters
long and this will become the search
line of your email queries can become
quite cumbersome so I updated it next is
the original search query from PubMed
you are also able to modify your search
terms from here if you edit your search
terms always remember to click test
search terms this will provide the
number of items based on the edited
search although I do not modify my
search it shows that there are 3131
results found at the time of the
screenshot do you want your new search
results sent automatically to your email
I do so yes please select
we will discuss a little later what
happens if you say no thanks
next visually confirm your email address
remembering that automatic email updates
can only be sent to email addresses that
have been confirmed if an email bounces
back three times the email address will
be changed to unconfirmed also you may
consider adding nih.gov
to your email safe list if you do not
know how to do this please contact your
email providers customer support for
assistance to verify that your email is
confirmed click on your username or
change as you can see the email address
has been confirmed otherwise a link
would appear allowing you to resend the
confirmation email okay
now let's return to save searches and
schedule the frequency of the email for
monthly choices include the first Sunday
through Saturday the first day of the
month the first week day of the month
weekly and finally daily next we will
select the format the choices are
summary abstract and MEDLINE let's take
a quick look at an actual email the
examples shown are from Outlook 2016 all
emails consist of the name of the save
search and in this one I re-edit it the
name senders message is optional text
that can be included in each email the
date sent the PubMed search terms the
ability to view the complete results in
PubMed the ability to edit the search
settings and of course unsubscribed
and finally the PubMed email results in
summary format here is an example of the
same result and how it appears in the
abstract format and in the MEDLINE
format back to our customized Save
Search
let the maximum number of items to
appear in the email in order to verify
that the email alert is running properly
send even when there aren't any new
search results in the event an update is
not sent out as scheduled or incomplete
the next scheduled update will include
the missing items here is where you can
include any optional text that you wish
to be added to your email and click Save
you will be immediately taken back to
the PubMed search page and will see the
confirmation here you will also be able
to edit the search at any time as needed
earlier I pointed out that you could
click no thanks to the email search
results let's take a quick look at my
NCBI where the saved search is stored
since we are logged into NCBI click the
my NCBI link located next to your
username as you can see in the safe
search portlet there are two PubMed
searches the one we just created a
lesson COPD and another lung cancer for
lung cancer I selected no thanks I do
not want email updates
the what's new column shows that there
are 220 citations currently available
since I last looked at my results three
days ago
what's new is available for all searches
for example if adolescent COPD is
delivered on a weekly basis I can still
log into NCBI to see if there were any
added citation since my last email run
and view the citations by clicking on
the numbered link the same search
portlet also has the ability to manage
saved searches from here you can quickly
look at your scheduled email delivery
and edit by clicking either the gear or
scheduled link if you check the box next
to your search name you are able to
delete the selected item or items and
also see what's new now let's talk about
building a collection by going back to
the my NCBI home page
my NCBI comes with the default
collections of my bibliography other
citations and favorites today we will be
creating a customizable titled
collection to share with others for your
convenience we have great tutorials on
our default collections that will be
included at the end of this presentation
although we are starting from save
searches you may also conduct a search
directly in PubMed remember if you click
on lung cancer beneath the PubMed search
column it will rerun the search and
display the results in PubMed
likewise if I click the link under
what's new I will have access to only
the 220 new citations based on my search
from here we are taken to PubMed which
consists of my new save search results
select a few of the citations for the
collection and click send to if all the
citations are to be included
simply click send to and up to 1,000
citations will be added to the
collection select the collections
destination verify the number of
selected items and click Add to
collections a pop-up window will
automatically show append to an existing
collection this is where the predefined
collection favorites and personally
titled collections will reside today we
are creating a new collection so we will
enter the name of the collection and
click Save we are returned to the PubMed
page where we will receive confirmation
of the saved items and the opportunity
to edit the collection lung cancer in my
NCBI remember you are always able to
return to the my NCBI home page by
clicking on the my NCBI link located
next to your username lung cancer now
appears in the collection today we will
click Edit to make the collection public
and to generate the URL to share in the
gold box
make it public and a confirmation of the
update will appear in the gold box along
with the generated URL for this
collection URL retrieval is located in
edit settings found in the gold toolbar
by clicking on the gear next to the
collection from the my NCBI home page or
the link private-public also located in
the my NCBI home page from the edit page
you can modify the name of the
collection make the collection private
or public retrieve the URL for the
public collection and gather the HTML
code if the collection is public and
change back to private the URL will no
longer work and the URL may change if
made public once again you may also wish
to save this collection in the display
setting located in the blue toolbar
click the down arrow to sort the
collection by date author or title
additionally iowa's may be selected by
checking the citation next to the box
clicking delete and clicking ok
selectively citations may personally be
viewed in the PubMed browser by clicking
view finally manage all collections from
here or from the my NCBI home page by
clicking manage collections merge and
delete are only available for custom
collections meaning that favorites my
bibliography and other citations cannot
be merged or deleted also you are able
to check the date less modified by
hovering over the text this concludes
the brief tutorial on how to create an
automated search create a collection and
activate a public URL if there are any
remaining questions please feel free to
ask them at this time and thank you once
again for joining us
ok thanks sherry there was one question
in the chat box that I didn't answer is
it not possible to
order collection to EndNote is the
question that I see here you are not
able to do it in your personalized
customized collection however you are
able to do it in either my bibliography
or other other citations there is a link
after after the questions which will
give you a step-by-step on how to export
from those collections meaning my
bibliography or other other citations
another question is is there a way to
automatically save collections as PDFs
not at this time but that is actually a
really great suggestion that we will
pass on okay thank you I don't have any
other questions in the questions pod
Cheri's showing the last slide here this
is some additional documents that you
might find helpful there's a two minute
PubMed search tutorials available here
and there is a youtube video on using my
bibliography and other citations and
just to remind you to keep up with NCBI
you can check in at our NCBI insights
blog of URLs given there NCBI insights
that NCBI NLM NIH gov and we do have a
YouTube channel
in CBI NLM is the username there so just
look for that on YouTube and for any
questions about help with NCBI resources
please write to info info at NCBI
NLM NIH gov if you have specific
questions about the webinars program
write to webinars its webinars at NCBI
NLM NIH stubb thanks everyone for coming
you